WAI CHEE DIMOCK: But the
part of the poem
actually has a reference to
the bell tolling, which is
kind of an eerie, totally
unplanned, I think, but kind of
nonetheless very strange,
accidental connection to For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
So "forlorn, the very word is
like a bell to toll me back
from thee to my soul self.
Adieu, the fancy cannot cheat
so well, as she is famed to
do, deceiving elf."
So even from what Fitzgerald
himself is reciting that
beauty cannot keep, that's the
note on which he ends.
And what is actually in the
Keats poem that is, once
again, is a tolling of a
bell, tolling your form
self back to you.
This novel is very much about
decline, about loss of what
used to be yours.
This is the story that Tender
is the Night is telling
someone with tremendous promise
early on in his life,
but basically losing
it gradually.
And it is that subtraction, that
process of subtraction,
things being taken away from
him, that the novel
chronicles.
So this novel--
I'm sure you're sick of
this at this point--
can very much be read within the
paradigm of have and have
not, Dick Diver and I
don't think I'm--
you probably--
well any case, it would be very
interesting, very useful
to think about Dick Diver once
again if yet another example
of someone who's struggling
between those two posts, have
and have not.
But the novel certainly
begins with a very
different note, right?
The very glamorous,
French Riviera.
And in fact, it's modeled on a
very glamorous couple, Gerald
and Sara Murphy.
So actually we can't really
see how magical they were.
But apparently they had this
circle of friends around them,
and every day was
a special day.
So the novel was supposedly
attributed to them.
And in fact, there was a
show at the Beinecke --
I think it was a couple years
ago-- called "Making it New."
The art of Gerald and Sara
Murphy very much attributed to
this very charismatic couple.
But in fact, Fitzgerald didn't
have to look too far.
He and his wife Zelda were quite
charismatic as well.
And certainly very much
part of that world.
This is a PBS feature on
Fitzgerald, and this image was
actually taken from it.
And this is another image of
Fitzgerald, his daughter
Scottie, and Zelda in the
French Riviera, 1926.
And those were really the
productive years.
The Great Gatsby came out in
'25, and then he was working
on this when he was at
the French Riviera.
But as we read on, we know that,
in fact, that glamour
and that magic probably
were not sustainable.
So his first novel was very
much about sustainability.
How long can that last.
And so there's a--
and in fact, it's almost
implicit in the way that they
were thought of as the
golden couple.
And Dorothy Parker, another
well-known novelist, said that
they did both look as
though they had just
stepped out of the sun.
So in the sense that they
lived in this completely
light-filled world.
But there's a different way in
which being in the sun can
have a different meaning
in Fitzgerald's career.
And it turned out in fact, his
only hugely successful novel
was his first novel.
And even The Great Gatsby, as we
know, didn't sell all that
well in his own lifetime.
It was out of print before
he died, in his
relatively short life.
So Fitzgerald, in order just to
make a living had to have
other jobs.
And he was a screenwriter in
Hollywood in the '30s.
And so there are a number of
books written about Fitzgerald
as a screenwriter.
This is Some Time in the Sun.
But it pretty much is a kind
or an ironic reference to
being in the sun, as we can see
from the pictures, it's
not such a glamorous
time to be a
screenwriter in Hollywood.
You're stuck with
your typewriter.
So the phrase that was used
for all the screenwriters,
including Fitzgerald, including
Faulkner, as we
know, so for all these people
was they were hacks with their
Underwood typewriter.
They were hack writers, not
having a lot of control over
the material.
Here is another book about
Fitzgerald in Hollywood.
And this is a picture
of him in the '30s
struggling pretty much.
There's a very important
collection of Fitzgerald's
screenplays, 2,000
pages, at the
University of South Carolina.
And Fitzgerald himself,
actually, also wrote 17
stories that were published in
Esquire magazine between
January of 1940 to May '41, and
then he died after that.
So it was actually published
after his death.
But they're The Pat
Hobby Stories.
There are 17 stories about this
screenwriter, down and
out screenwriter in Hollywood.
And basically very alcoholic,
so quite autobiographical.
So we know that film, actually,
was front and center
for Fitzgerald pretty much from
the '20s to the '30s, and
very much till the
end of his life.
So it is really a very organic
part of his career.
So what I'd like to do today is
to talk about the ways in
which cinematic techniques get
translated into linguistic and
textual techniques.
And especially I wanted to
look at two phenomena,
flashback, which is very much
something that was used in
Hollywood films. But also
montage, something that was
used more in European films,
especially in the Russian
cinema, but was gradually making
its way to mainstream
Hollywood film as well.
So the structure for today's
lecture, I'll begin with the
publication history of Tender
is the Night, which actually
it first came out
in a magazine,
and then two editions.
The first edition has a
flashback, and the '51 edition
much later, actually
turned it into a
chronological narrative.
What we see today, actually, is
a restoration to that 1934
edition with the flashback,
and I'll give
you details of that.
So because the narrative order
of Tender is the Night is in
some sense switchable or
reversible, we'll be looking
at phenomenon of switchability
or
reversibility in three ways.
One is looking at sequence of
adjectives, how they are
reversible.
We'll be looking at the relation
between actor and
accessory or appendage.
And we'll be looking at the
relation between proper nouns
and active verbs.
So a grammatical relation, a
kind of reversibility of
grammatical relation.
And then we'll be looking at
montage as a technique, and
the way that that is played
out in thematic ways.
But first of all, the
publication history of Tender
is the Night.
We're very used to this.
Authors quite often would
publish first in magazines.
So it came out in four
installments
in Scribner's magazine.
And Scribner's also published
the novel in '34.
So this is the first edition
of the novel.
And then it came out as a Bantam
edition, $0.35 in 1951
So the two editions, there's a
huge difference between the
two editions.
The '34 edition, book one,
begins in 1925, and then
there's a jump back to eight
years ago, back to 1917.
So it begins basically with Dick
Diver and his family in
the French Riviera.
And then it goes back when he
was just a young doctor, just
the beginning, the very
beginning of his career full
of promise, 1917.
And then it goes back to a later
point of his life, 1930.
So this is the edition that was
published, that Fitzgerald
originally published.
And some critics objected to
this out of sequence, this not
chronological narrative.
So when it came out as the
Bantam classic that was
switched, and it began
chronologically.
It began with Dick Diver's
early promise as a young
doctor, and then it just
proceeds chronologically.
So reversing the order of the
'34 edition, and eliminating
the flashback.
So we can talk a little bit-- in
fact, I would encourage you
to think more in section about
why it is important for
Fitzgerald to have
the flashback.
What effect is achieved by
having a narrative that is out
of sequence?
And I hope that I'll be talking
a little bit about
that in the lectures as well.
But I would encourage you to
have your opinion, really,
about this.
But today I wanted to
concentrate, because we
haven't read so far into the
novel, I wanted to concentrate
on switchability or
reversibility as a relatively
small scale phenomenon.
Not so much looking at the
narrative form as reversible,
but looking at very minute
details within the novel that
are reversible.
So the order of appearance of
adjectives can be seen as
reversible.
This is just one example.
"Nearest her, on the other side,
a young woman lay under
a roof of umbrellas making out
a list of things from a book
open on the sand.
Her bathing suit was pulled off
her shoulders and her back
a ruddy, orange brown, set off
by a string of creamy pearls,
shown in the sun.
Her face was hard and
lovely and pitiful."
So those adjectives
don't go together.
Usually they are not seen in
such close proximity, "hard,"
and "lovely," and "pitiful." And
just to have those three
adjectives, they are lined
up in that particular way
generates kind of a
mini narrative.
So this is one way in which
the order of appearance of
adjectives is a case of a kind
of a mini narrativization of a
description, even though it
seems to be just descriptive.
Nonetheless, there's an implicit
narrative suggests
that by that order of
appearance, and the narrative
would be different if we were
to reverse the order.
If her face were pitiful and
lovely and hard it would be a
different narrative.
And Fitzgerald's not going to
let those adjectives go, as
you will see.
So right here, we also have this
additional image that her
shoulders and back are ruddy and
orange brown, and there's
a string of creamy pearls
around her neck.
When Fitzgerald comes back to
this detail, he does something
else for that detail.
So this is him revising himself
all the time, revising
his mini narrative
all the time.
"Nicole Diver, her brown back
hanging from her pearls, was
looking through a recipe book
for chicken Maryland." Her
brown back hanging
from the pearls.
Before it was pearls hanging
around her neck.
All of a sudden there's a
reversible relation between
the actor and the appendage, so
that is it her brown back
that is hanging from
the pearls.
So this suggests that the pearls
are very important,
that maybe money is
very important.
Really is about whether the
money is more important than
human beings, or vice versa.
So once again, this more than--
in fact, more than just
a mini narrative, but kind of
the whole vision of the world,
whole vision of the relation
in between humanity and
economy is suggested by the
very, very micro detail of the
reversible relation between
"back" and "pearls." So I
would say that reversibility is
really the key player all
through the novel.
Operation off scales operates
between adjectives, operate
between different books, the
three main books of the novel.
And they operate on the shape
of Dick Diver's career.
So very, very important
concept.
But just to give you one more
example of a very local micro
instance of switchability or
reversibility has to do with
the transitive relation between
proper names and
active verbs.
So we know that there's a
character in a novel called
Dick Diver.
And here's Rosemary, the
actress, talking about what
she does and what
she has to do.
She has a fever, but because
the set is very expensive,
they just have to shoot.
So this is what she has to do.
She has to dive into the
water for that episode.
"One day I happened to have the
grippe and didn't know it
and they were taking a
scene where I dove
into a canal in Venice.
It was a very expensive set so
I had to dive and dive and
dive all morning."
And obviously, it's not a
trivial or unconnected detail
in a novel where
the protagonist
is called Dick Diver.
That there should be someone
else diving and diving and
diving, because of her
discipline as an actress.
So I think that right then and
there, the question opens up
who is more capable of a kind
of sustainable performance?
It seems that just the
repetition of those three
words, "dive and dive and dive
all morning" suggest that
Rosemary is probably going to be
an actress who will have a
long career because she's
so disciplined and just
hardworking that if she has to
do something she would do it.
So the question then, because
she seems to have such a
sustainable career, sustainable
performance,
whether Dick Diver is capable
of that sustainable
performance, the person who has
that proper name, whether
he can actually live up
to the promise of
his name, Dick Diver.
So I want now to really
zero-in on those two
adjectives, "hard" and
"pitiful," and look at the way
Fitzgerald really spins
out a whole narrative.
Basically, maybe the whole
novel is based on the
interplay between those
two adjectives.
So let's look at what the
hard Nicole does.
And what comes through, what
kind of story emerges when we
go along the axis of Nicole
as a hard person.
This is what she says to
Rosemary just talking casually
about the beach and so on,
and about the tourists.
"Well, I have felt there were
too many people on the beach
this summer," Nicole admitted.
"Our beach that Dick made out
of a pebble pile," she
considered, and then lowering
her voice out of range of the
trio of nannies who sat back
under another umbrella,
"Still, they're preferable to
those British last summer who
kept shouting about: 'Isn't
the sea blue?
Isn't the sky white?
Isn't little Nellie's nose red?'
Rosemary thought she
would not like to have
Nicole for an enemy."
So I think that this is a great
demonstration of a hard
person without this person
actually lifting a finger to
do a thing.
It's just the way
her mind works.
It is her tone of voice, it is
the way she thinks about
nannies, people in her employ.
The way she thinks about people
who don't have to cling
to the beach that she does.
It's really the speech pattern
and the tone of voice of
someone who's never not been
on the top of the world, as
she looks down on everyone,
and just
putting them in the places.
So this is the hard Nicole.
It actually gives another
meaning to her back hanging
from the string of pearls.
That may be, really, this is
what the real Nicole is.
It is the fact that she
is hanging from
the string of pearls.
That they will always be a
string of pearls for her to
hang from that she can afford
to look at the world in this
way, look at other people in
this way, and speak in that
particular tone of voice that
signals to Rosemary-- it takes
about two seconds for Rosemary
to know what kind of a person
she is dealing with.
So she casts a summary of what
a person is without recourse
to any action.
And in fact, Nicole doesn't
really act until the very end
of the novel.
And even then it's not even
especially hard kind of
action, although that's
debatable.
But as is the case with
Fitzgerald, the word "hard,"
it's not allowed to stand alone,
because we can't forget
that in fact, there were three
adjectives, "hard," and
"lovely" and "pitiful." So that
kind of permutation, it's
like a dance, a dance
of adjectives, will
keep coming up again.
So just a few pages later, now
the description of Nicole, her
face at different times,
the "hard" as to be
in quotation marks.
"Her face was hard, almost
stern, save for the soft gleam
of piteous doubt that looked
from her green eyes." So it
seems that those adjectives
are really ingrained in
Fitzgerald's mind.
That he cannot think about
Nicole without using that
trio, "lovely," as well as --
of maybe just a duo of two
adjectives.
They are the two poles of the
spectrum on which she shadows
back and forth.
So because "pitiful" is so
much a companion to the
adjective, "hard." Let's look at
one instance of the pitiful
Nicole, and see whether or not
there is an organic connection
between the "pitiful" Nicole
and the "hard" Nicole.
And we have to go back
earlier, so we
have to go back to--
well go forward to book two,
which is backward in time.
Go back to 1917 when she was a
patient, and Dick Diver was
about to-- well actually, he
had not even agreed to do
anything for her.
He was just someone who had
been consulted about her.
And she was writing to him when
she was in this mental
institution.
"Dear Captain Diver, I write to
you because there's no one
else to whom I can turn and
it seems to me if this
farcicle"--
misspelled by Nicole--
"if this farcicle situation is
apparent to one as sick as me
it should be apparent to you.
The mental trouble is all over
and besides that I am
completely broken and
humiliated, if that was what
they wanted.
My family have shamefully
neglected me, there's no use
asking them for help or pity.
I have had enough and it is
simply ruining my health and
wasting my time pretending that
what is the matter with
my head is curable."
So this is the absolute
low point for Nicole.
She is by herself.
Her family isn't there, she's in
the hands of strangers who
are paid to take care of her.
And here, who is this person
who seems to have his whole
life full of promise ahead of
him, completely healthy, about
to be launching this
great career.
So in one sense it is Nicole
at her most abject.
That this is someone who really
has no future to look
forward to.
Has really no hope, really,
has nothing
that she can claim.
Except that given the fact that
we have seen the hard
Nicole, I think that we should
also be alert a little bit to
the suggestion of hardness,
even in this moment when
Nicole is most object.
And I think that, in fact,
that misspelled word,
"farcicle," points to a
different linguistic usage.
Some reason he uses the word
"farcicle," actually, is more
in command of the faculties
than is suggested by the
profession of abjection
likewise.
Likewise, it is simply "ruining
my health and wasting
my time." Someone who would use
the phrase "waste my time"
has a different sense of herself
than is suggested by
the profession of abjection.
So right there, even though it
is the pitiful Nicole who is
in the foreground, an element
of hardness is never not on
the horizon.
I think that it is really that
combination that Fitzgerald
wants us to see that she's
completely switchable.
The distance between hardness
and pitifulness is tiny.
She can just go back and forth,
it takes one second for
her to switch from
one to the other.
So one more instance of
the pitiful Nicole.
This one is very late in her
life, so this is in the
present for her.
"Nicole knelt beside the tub
swaying sidewise and sidewise.
"It's you!" she cried, "It's
you come to intrude on the
only privacy I have in the world
-- with your spread of
red blood on it.
I'll wear it for you --
I'm not ashamed, though
it was such a pity."
So the word "pity"
is foregrounded.
But once again, even though
this is Nicole out of her
mind, Nicole totally out of
control, Nicole gone crazy
again, and therefore, she
has to be medicalized.
Nicole is a candidate
for medicalization.
But even though she's a
candidate for medicalization,
she's also quite aggressive,
as well as we can see.
She's not so defenseless as
not to be able to say some
pretty wounding things to
whoever would listen to her.
So once again we have that
combination, the pitifulness
in the foreground, but hardness
is always lurking
very, very close to the front,
actually, in the background.
So it's because of that, I
think, it's because the
distance between the two
switchable platforms is such a
small distance, that I think
that the technique of montage
is especially helpful
to Fitzgerald.
As I said before, I don't
think it was actually a
mainstream Hollywood technique
in the '20s yet, although it
was already theorized by film
theorists all over the world.
I'll give you one instance
of that.
But basically, montage is a
film editing technique.
And the two things that are
central to it are dissolving
from one narrative into another,
and superimposition
of one onto another.
So these are two fundamental
elements of montage.
And Sergei Eisenstein, the
Russian, great filmmaker in
the '20s, he wrote
a lot on montage.
In fact, I think that most
people who actually talk about
montage go back to Eisenstein's
writing in the 1920s.
So according to Eisenstein,
"Montage is the nerve of
cinema." In the collision of
different narratives, "each
sequential element is perceived
not next to the
other, but on top of the other."
Even though they are
sequential, even though one
comes after the other.
And basically there's
no way we can--
this is how time works.
One thing comes after another,
the structure of time.
There's no way we can completely
do without that, or
completely undermine that.
But nonetheless, it's a way of
storytelling that makes that
sequential appearance almost
case of superimposition.
And I think that this is really
what Fitzgerald does
for a good part of the time
in Tender is the Night.
So let's just look at five or
six instances of what I would
call different modes
of superimposition.
Or superimposition being mapped
on different kinds of
thematics that are themselves
interrelated.
So war, we began with
war in the very
beginning of this semester.
And it turns out that war would
come back in quite a big
way in this novel that
really otherwise has
nothing to do with war.
This is a novel set in the
French Riviera, and then
basically in various civilian
and very luxurious settings.
So it really has nothing
to do with war.
Except that for some reason,
war keeps coming up in very
strange illusions.
So one of the first instances of
this, and usually it comes
out in casual conversation.
So sometimes between a major
character, and sometimes
between a minor character.
So this is a conversation
between Rosemary and Tommy
Barban who's a mercenary.
Actually, I didn't know
that that was such an
important class of--
that was such an important
profession, but it turns out
that maybe it was in the early
twentieth century.
So Tommy, because he's a
mercenary, and he goes around
from one place to
another, "Home?
I have no home.
I am going to a war." "What
war?" "What war?
Any war.
I haven't seen a paper lately
but I suppose there's a war--
there always is." "Don't
you care what you fight
for?" "Not at all --
so long as I'm well treated.
When I'm in rut I come to see
the Divers, because then I
know that in a few weeks
I'll want to go to
war." Rosemary stiffened.
"You like the Divers,"
she reminded him.
"Of course--
especially her--
but they make me want
to go to war."
Tommy Barban might be a
mercenary, but he certainly is
not just brute strength.
There's a lot of psychological
subtlety at play here.
This is page 30.
So we have no understanding
of what context
Tommy Barban is speaking.
All we can say is that it is
not an innocent context.
That he has lots of things that
he's holding back about
how he feels about the Divers is
clear, that he doesn't like
Dick Diver, right?
That I like them,
especially her.
But also the general sense
that it's just the two of
them, for a few weeks is enough,
that is enough to make
him want to go to war.
We don't know what it is about
them that would have this kind
of effect on him.
But it never fails.
So right there and there, this
is a snake making its way into
this paradise that is
the French Riviera.
The least we can say that even
amount the close friends and
people who are right there, who
are there constantly with
them, they're people who
supposedly are very good
friends of theirs have this
opinion about them.
So we have-- this is just one
mystery that we have to figure
out, and the details
of which we have to
fill out for ourselves.
And in fact, I would suggest
that even at the very end of
the novel, I'm not sure that
we can completely clear up
this mystery.
But it's just sitting there, and
it's the superimposition
of love and war that creates
the particular kind of
psychological dynamics between
Rosemary and Tommy, and also
between Tommy and the Divers.
So it is not even visual.
So I just want to emphasize that
when the film technique
of montage is used in
a novel, it doesn't
always have to be visual.
It can just be a case of
psychological superimposition,
although sometimes Fitzgerald
also uses very, very visual
superimposition as well.
But just to give you one more
example of how persistent
Fitzgerald is about
superimposing these
two, love and war.
So they go and they walk out,
and it turns out that even
here in this seemingly very
peaceful setting, that
actually World War I was
fought very close by.
So close by that the relics of
World War I was still there.
And this is the spot, actually,
where the British
could only advance a foot at a
time, and the resistance was
so fierce that they could
only move ahead one foot
at a time, the army.
And it cost 20 lives
to date for them to
go forward one foot.
"This land here cost twenty
lives a foot that summer," he
said to Rosemary.
She looked out obediently at
the rather bare green plain
with its low trees of
six years' growth.
If Dick has added that they
were now being shelled she
would have believed him
that afternoon.
Her love had reached a point
where now at last, she was
beginning to be unhappy,
to be desperate.
She didn't know what to do --
she wanted to talk to her
mother."
So here Rosemary is
deeply in love.
She is in the throes of love, of
what seems to be unrequited
love for Dick, and the necessary
background is World
War I. That it is the fact that
she would have believed
him if he had told her that they
were being shelled, once
again, as in World War I, that
she would have believed him if
he had said that, that
is the measure of how
much in love she is.
So it seems that love is really
not a freestanding
entity in his novel.
It's always mapped against
large-scale warfare.
We don't simply know.
The logic of that mapping
is not clear.
In fact, I would also say that
this is another one of those
mysteries that even at the end
of the novel, we might not be
able to say exactly
what the logic is.
But clearly, for Fitzgerald
there's a logic that always,
persistently, we saw it in
this cross-mapping or
superimposition of
love and war.
One more example just to see
how obsessed he is, really,
with this kind of
cross-mapping.
General Grant -- so it's
not just World War I,
but the Civil War.
And this is something that
Fitzgerald has in common with
Hemingway as well in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
We see that Spanish Civil War
and the American Civil War
sometimes cross-mapped in the
importance of Robert Jordan's
grandfather.
Here, for no reason that we can
see, the Civil War comes
into play, in the midst of the
discussion about World War I.
"General Grant invented this
kind of battle at Petersburg
in sixty-five." "No,
he didn't --
he just invented
mass butchery.
This kind of battle was invented
by Lewis Carroll and
Jules Verne and whoever wrote
Undine, and country deacons
bowling and marraines in
Marseilles and girls seduced
in the back lanes of Wurtemburg
and Westphalia.
Why, this was a love-battle --
there was a century of
middle-class love spent here.
This was the last
love-battle."
Totally enigmatic use of
the English language.
Love battle is not a phrase that
anyone else would use.
Fitzgerald uses it as if
it was a most idiomatic
expression in the world.
And that's because in his mind
there is such a tight knit
between love and war that you
almost cannot talk about one
without talking about
the other.
But according to this apparent
analysis of war, it is really
middle-class romantic love that
is at the back of war.
It's a very long causal chain
to go from middle-class love
to trench warfare, or to the
Civil War in the US history.
It's a very, very long causal
chain, and we have to fill in
lots of lots of relays in order
for that causal change
to make sense.
But that's what Fitzgerald
wants us to imagine is to
imagine all those missing
links that
he's not showing us.
So this is I think that we've
seen enough to know that this
really is a very significant
pattern not
explained to us, obviously.
But that is one of the constants
in this novel is
that extreme conditions of love
always require a very
violent, large-scale violent
background for it to be fully
manifested.
That maybe his articulation
requires some relation to that
large-scale event.
So I want to turn now
to talk about--
we've been looking at kind
of the narrative mapping.
So a large-scale, historical
event that's constantly being
summoned and reactivated and
brought into a novel.
So that's this one is on a macro
register that has the
micro romantic relation.
But it turns out that that
combination of love and war
can also be played out in very,
very incidental moments
not involving the protagonist at
all, which suggests that it
is the narrative fabric, it's
a descriptive fabric that
Fitzgerald is--
it's almost like a stylistic
take for Fitzgerald without
even making a huge thematic
point about it.
That's what his mind
reverts to.
Whenever he talks about any kind
of violence, there's also
this other element of love
that is superimposed.
So this is a totally trivial
incident, except for the fact
that it's just the same
kind of dynamics.
"At a Pullman entrance two
cars off, a vivid scene
detached itself from the tenor
of many farewells.
The young woman with the
helmet-like hair to whom
Nicole had spoken made an odd
dodging little run away from
the man to whom she was talking
and plunged a frantic
hand into her purse; then the
sound of two revolver shots
cracked the narrow air
of the platform...
But before the crowd closed in,
the others had seen the
shot take effect, seen the
target sit down upon the
platform."
People constantly getting shot
in this novel, which is really
a surprising fact, for that
murder to appear with this
kind of regularity in this
particular kind of social
setting, but it does.
So that in itself is a very
insistent pattern on the part
of Fitzgerald.
But I want to call
attention to this
highly cinematic moment.
The beginning was just
kind of the usual
scene at a train station.
People are saying goodbye.
But really, the introduction
of a textural element that
actually could be filmed with
perfect to maximum effect, the
young woman with the
helmet-like hair.
A completely gratuitous detail
that would not have called
attention to itself--
would not otherwise have called
attention to itself,
but in this novel, given
the superimposition of
love and war does.
So it's the helmet-like
hair who is a
total stranger to Nicole.
That Nicole has spoken "made an
odd dodging little run away
from a man to whom she was
talking, and plunged a little
frantic hand into her purse."
It's that almost dance steps
taken by that woman.
It's this as a kind of dance
movement, and then the shot
coming after that as the not
predictable, not expected
conclusion to that dance
movement that creates this
montage effect.
She's been talking to Nicole,
she's making a little run.
Maybe we would expect someone
who's making a little run in a
train station to go and
catch the train.
That's the most usual context
for the little running, except
it was a dodging little run.
It turns out that the outcome
of that little run is, in
fact, the shooting.
So two completely separate
narratives being mapped onto
one another.
They're much more standard and
surprising are they with
saying goodbye in the train
station with a totally
different story being
mapped onto it.
And it turns out that the two
can actually share a lot of
the same visual details unless
there's a divergence, and the
violence of that divergence that
create that particular
cinematic effect.
So I just want to give you one
more example of this highly
cinematic rendition of murder.
And it turns out that Fitzgerald
is especially
interested in the way that the
sequence leading up to a
murder, or the sequence by
which murder is finally
recognized as murder.
So here is a description of
something that happens in
Rosemary's room, hotel room.
And it takes a long time
to get to the end.
I think that that's the point.
So let's follow Fitzgerald
in this very,
very strange passage.
"Then, rather gradually, she
realized without turning about
that she was not alone
in the room.
In an inhabited room they are
refracting objects only half
noticed: varnished wood, more or
less polished brass, silver
and ivory, and beyond these a
thousand conveyors of light
and shadow so mild that one
scarcely thinks of them as
that, the tops of picture
frames, the edge of the
pencils or ash-trays, of crystal
or china ornaments;
the totality of this
refraction --
appealing to equally subtle
reflexes of the vision as well
as those associational fragments
in the subconscious
that we seem to hang on to, as
a glass-fitter keeps the
irregularly shaped pieces
that may do some time --
this fact might account for
what Rosemary afterward
mysteriously described as
"realizing" that there was
some one in the room, before
she could determine it.
But when she did realize it she
turned swift in a sort of
ballet step and saw that a dead
Negro was stretched upon
her bed."
This has got to be the most
deferred discovery of a dead
body in any work of American
literature.
It seems almost
counterproductive for the
realization on the part of
Rosemary that she was not
alone in the room to the fact
that yes, there's a dead negro
on the bed.
Why Fitzgerald would want to
take that long detour to me,
actually, once again, is not
completely transparent.
All we can say is that this is
a kind of cinematic moment
when we soon know that something
is wrong in a room.
But instead the focus is kept
frozen, fixated, on all these
refracting objects.
Varnished wood, ashtrays,
and so on.
All these refracting objects
that are actually not
reflecting that dead body.
So this is a really weird kind
of way in which there are
multiple mirrors in a room, all
these refracting surfaces,
but they're not reflecting the
central, the most important,
crucial factor in that room,
the dead body on the bed.
Instead, it seems simply to be
a meditation on the way the
world comes to us refracted, and
there are multiple objects
to be doing that, and the
relation between that and our
subconscious, and the relation
between that and our memory.
So almost a kind of a meditation
on the way in which
our memory is structured
by visual refractions.
And then finally coming
back to Rosemary.
And even then repeating
exactly the
same sequence, right.
There's the woman before has
this dodging little run before
she plunges a hand
into her purse to
pull out the revolver.
And here, Rosemary's not going
to plunge into her purse, but
she's going to do a little
ballet dance, a ballet step
before she discovers the
dead body on the bed.
So this is all, we can say,
really, is maybe just describe
and re-articulate what
Fitzgerald is doing is highly
delivered, it's highly stylized,
one of the most
stylized moment, consciously,
maybe even heavy-handedly
written, although to what end
is not entirely clear.
But it's one of the most
purposeful moments in novel.
So I think that we are obligated
to interpret it in
some fashion, and to attach some
degree of thematic weight
to this seemingly inexplicable
moment.
So I always used to say that
Tender is the Night is just a
real challenge to us, as much
of a challenge as Faulkner's
novels are.